it feels like it belongs to someone else
gentlemen i got to see the first episode
and this is an
action tv show let me tell you so
i'll start with you sebastian do you
think that you had to do more getting
prepared for this one
or was it about the same as doing the
films i mean it felt the same in the
sense that
they always feel big and they always
feel like a big challenge and an
undertaking and so on and there's a
familiarity to that
but i think here it was a little
challenging just because
we knew we were taking these characters
into new territory and exploring their
past
finally in their a day in their life so
we needed to kind of
make sure that what auntie and i think
is funny
generally uh is funny
yeah y'all have a great like 80s uh
buddy comedy thing going on with this
with all of this crazy action
but there's a missing presence in this
one and so anthony i want to start with
you about
you know sort of moving on both of your
stories past cap
and what you were interested in
exploring this time around sam's
back story for me is really interesting
because of
the great stan lee and how he created
and evolved
the falcon throughout the course of the
comic book for
the marvel universe um so bringing
sam into the new fold after the blip
in a new reality seeing how he
reacclimates to society
was something that i was really excited
about interested
i was really interested in uh you know
cracking that open and seeing how
how and what that would look like i love
that i think folks uh
you're gonna get to see both your
characters in a different way and i'm
not gonna re
litigate the whole shield thing because
i know y'all have done that
but sebastian do you think you could
take the mantle for
america's ass because we did an
interview with anthony where he was very
certain that he had america's ass locked
down do you think you could maybe take
that mantle and he takes the shield
you do not want to go against the round
brown homeboy
i have to say i have skipped one
too many leg days in my time to be able
to
keep up with the thighs of oak
that are sitting out there in new
orleans as they speak and i got to tell
you those squats they keep things
high high and tight
count me up well
again that's i mean listen
he might have those uh he might have
those uh biceps but
he ain't got nothing down there
[Laughter]
so we're both out in the in the desert
i appreciate your honesty um they're
wrapping me pretty soon but i definitely
wanted to ask you
this is
moving past not having the shield what
do you think
uh bucky's gonna be trying to sort of
figure out this time around since he
doesn't have the shield there's
something interesting i think in his
story too right oh of course his place
in the world you know and
and his connection to sort of like the
times that he's finding himself
in and and and letting go of the past
and moving forward
and obviously a new friendship you know
uh
and and and expanding his horizons so to
speak you know he's kind of like
a bitter old dude in in a way like and
he needs to sort of
grow up a lot that show represents a lot
of things to a lot of people
[Applause]
you know coming after this sort of like
phenomenon that was one division i'm
wondering uh
folks are wondering if you're gonna have
some wtf moments like lined up for
falcon and the winter soldier
well i hope so absolutely are you
kidding me
are you kidding i mean
it's the the weekly episode structure
though you know what i mean like this
whole idea of like going back to the way
people used to watch tv
how did you guys maybe approach that
from a storytelling um aspect for
you know again something that's going to
be on disney plus but
you know still have that like sort of
week to week waiting for it to come out
sort of anticipation well it's
interesting because of course you
you know you want to leave the audience
with sort of breathless
so we definitely chose we we made it
like a movie though if you watched all
six together it will feel like a
six hour movie um so it's cohesive
that way but then we kind of sliced it
up
um at the at the sort of perfect moments
where you
uh are standing going what next wow you
know so
um that it obviously is worth waiting
for the week
otherwise so hopefully people will will
feel that way but um
but yeah so we definitely you know were
very conscious of of how we left each
episode
what will be interesting is you know
with the anticipation each week
and the conversations it's really um fun
to see
you know the engagement which i'm
thrilled about so
one division and you know hopefully
we're as lucky uh in terms of
people just talking i think you will be
just a little guess i'm not going to go
out on a limb here but
so you're going to be checking the
hashtags i'm guessing right like see
of course i won't be posting though
i will i will be quiet just let him get
just lurking
lurk that's the best way to do the
internet um so bringing it back
to baron zemo because obviously i don't
blame you for wanting to get daniel
bruhl i would cast him in you know
anything i could but
why that particular villain um for these
two because i do think it's an
interesting um
sort of setup making him the big bad uh
well
do we know he's the big bad do we know
anything oh look at you
you are good
well bringing him back what was the
thought process for wanting to bring him
into the fold
uh just that he's a very interesting
character this is a very complex story
that has a twists and turns and as
part of his narrative uh and his
backstory
it folded very nicely into our big
themes
and so um you know he offers a lot as a
character
uh you know not only uh and he also
offers a lot
uh in terms of the the bucky sam
dynamic and and their their conversation
their ongoing conversation
well i would ask you the same question
about sharon but i think they've trained
you guys
too well and so you're not gonna give me
anything away
but um let's talk about something you
can't talk about and that's working with
uh sebastian and anthony who are just
they're kind of a buddy comedy anywhere
they go but
just adding them to this i knew that
this was like such a perfect combination
to give them their own big story so yeah
talk about working with them
well you know they're terrific uh the
both of them are super professional
and uh you know even though they do love
to um
uh you know set each other up and laugh
and all that
they come to set so prepared and very
thoughtful about their characters
you know they've been living in these
characters for many years and so
it has been a thrill to be part of
seeing them and be
uh you know supporting them in finding
the new
the new nuances to these characters
because for the first time
we go behind the curtain we really see
who they are and we get inside bucky's
head and we get inside sam's life and
and um these were places that they
hadn't been to with the characters
they've never had the time
um you know just straight real estate to
uh
to to go there so we have tremendously
strong performers
who um who you know pick up the pick up
that
baton and really uh make us care
and i i think it was that's going to be
something really thrilling for the uh
the fans is how much time we get to be
with these characters because unlike the
movies
you know i call the movies the snacks
and we're like the mail and
um so we get to you know really save her
we also
don't have to go in a straight line from
beginning to end we can we can wander we
can go with the characters on a few
different a few different paths so
twists and turns are are um you know
going to be our friend
oh i'm just going to say you're setting
up all kinds of timeline things for me
when you say it's not going in a
straight line but we will wait we will
see what happens
um but if you could maybe talk about
like
since you can't talk specifics what's
some show that folks if they say hey
if you were watching this show you're
gonna see a lot in
um falcon in the winter soldier maybe
just kind of give people a little bit of
a taste of what they might do
even though obviously it's its own thing
you know it really is i
i honestly can't uh point you in a
direction on that one
it honestly is its own unique thing i
mean we did
in terms of the buddy cop of it um
uh you know we did a lot of looking at
relationship movies uh in that sort of
genre from the 70s and 80s
um so that we i think
i think that would be more the paradigm
uh because
we are on a ride with these two very
unlikely people who have
some common there's a common thread to
their existence they've experienced
many of the same things they've they're
they've both lost a very good friend
um so uh there is a commonality between
them but
uh but just like the body top of it they
also aren't actually friends and they
don't necessarily want to be friends
um even though they're kind of stuck
together so i would say it's more that
uh than a particular show i i do think
um it is very marvel so it will have all
and yet it's it's evolved because it's a
very uh grounded world that we're in
so it's it's evolved to a place um where
we can be with as i said earlier that we
can be with the characters and we can
go on journeys with them um but it's all
very real world
and so i think the other thing is
relevance that we will really
feel the conversation we're having some
deep conversations about the shield
um about a black man carrying the shield
does he want to do that
does he what does he feel about that um
you know how does bucky think about that
and and what is
uh because everybody has a different
experience with the shield
or has different opinions about the
shield how relevant is
captain america at all you know what
what is all
so we really unpack some very
interesting
um issues uh at a time when this
conversation
is incredibly relevant wow i'm i'm very
excited to see that
and you know i know that you know you
mentioned him
and i obviously he's not going to be
present well i don't know maybe he'll be
president of the series but i think
cap's presence will be felt throughout
this so if you could maybe give us the
line to sort of encompass
how he will maybe sort of influence the
show
from his absence even well i think
that's
that's the way to think about it is that
he um
you know back in at the end of end game
he started a chain of events
um and we are the chain of events so
by definition uh he's a friend of two
people
who miss him and he so he's always
he's always present he's in some form
because
they're they're navigating the fact that
they lost a friend
[Music]
symbols are nothing without the women
and men that give them meaning
uh malcolm congratulations on the show
it's going to be the first show
after one division though it wasn't
intended to be that way but
i think folks got very much primed for
wtf moments with that show um do you
guys
have some of those in store for us this
season absolutely
it is born from the same stock um
um and you know marvel knows how to do
that better than anybody
yeah what was it like doing that sort of
episodic writing again because
with most streaming services you know
you're doing it intended for
you know a binge but with disney plus
there's going to be folks sort of tuning
in week to week have you guys made it
feel more throwback-y in that way to
those old-school sort of like long crime
dramas
it's it's interesting like the
storytelling
is all interwoven and one continuum over
to six episodes
um um the debate on how to release them
as far as like one at a time or
binge was had in earnest with kevin
and everyone uh uh over at marvel
and the decision really came from a very
pure place
of how that like everyone involved with
these projects are fans to the core
and so they feel like
if we can satisfy our own experience we
know we're going to be on
satisfying the fans experience and
that's how they decided on the week to
week but
really the it is it is one long story
with these with with them like each the
individual episodes
go together seamlessly excellent and uh
let's just say you know
they're bringing back baron zemo for the
first time just kind of
curious uh what's it like writing for
that character you know
more than like a cameo obviously like an
entire series
it was great like he just like bucky all
of these characters
showed up with so much baggage that had
been left particularly after civil war
right that we knew what we had to attack
with them
zemo is really dealing with the fact
that his country was destroyed by his
city
which killed his family you know what
i'm saying
um and the belief that superheroes and
supremacy go hand in hand
and it's just not healthy for the planet
um the crazy thing was
we we created sort of a playful
character with zemo and daniel bruhl
just took
everything out the park i mean man he's
cold
yeah i think most folks got introduced
to him in glorious bastards but yeah
he's
he's an incredible incredible actor
joined by
you know our falcon and winter soldier
anthony and sebastian they have just
this natural chemistry
is that something that you're like
leaning into when you're writing like
how
how is that sort of sprinkled throughout
because you can tell even from the first
episode
this is gonna have that sort of like 80s
maybe 90s buddy cop
feel that's exactly what we was going
for and how you
how can you deny it you know the second
everyone saw them together in civil war
i feel like this series was inevitable
after that moment you know what i'm
saying
and what we try to do is position
scenes and scenarios in a way that
they understand them so well that they
can play with them
because it is electric and you know it's
worth a billion dollars just to have two
people
that have that kind of like jazz
together you know
yeah it's very it's priceless literally
you can't really sort of like recreate
it
um just really quickly though because
this is such an action
show how are those written how far in
advance
are those action sequence written or do
you just put parentheses
big explosions
we those action sequences are
broken down in detail but not only that
we approach them by putting character
story like a thread of like
at this phase of the action the it's
affecting the characters in this way
by midway into action the characters are
responding like this you know i'm saying
like so there's a whole mini character
story
happening in each set piece then you
hand them to the geniuses at marvel
and everything you thought it could be
gets magnified by a million because they
take it in their own direction
and freak it to the ninth degree
i'm sorry i'm gonna have to steal that
line freaking ninth degree
i'll credit you but uh probably not um
you're all good girl let's uh let's talk
about cap though obviously
well as far as you're gonna answer me we
think he's gonna be
pretty much absent from the series and
so folks are curious
how that sort of ghost-like presence is
gonna sort of
affect these two these two heroes it's
funny you're keying in on
all the main stuff um this entire series
is defined by cap's absence
where post blip thanos is gone
and half the world's population has
suddenly appeared and spun the world
into chaos right and that's the kind of
problem that only cap really is equipped
to solve
and then on top of that you have
villains who are responding to that
absence of cap and this chaos
and then you have heroes who are not
only responding to those villains
but are in their personal life dealing
with the fact that
they're they had a mutual best friend in
common
he's gone they don't even know if
they're friends now you know what i'm
saying because steve's not there to do
it so
the spectre cap is in every scene and
defines the entire series
it's interesting that you mentioned that
um they they don't know if they're
friends because it's like a kind of an
odd couple literally like they're very
much like this one doesn't like this
about this this one doesn't like that
about
that and so are there any other
properties that maybe you could point
folks to to say
hey if you want to know what flavor to
look forward to
in 100 what you got here is the bullseye
it was
48 hours lethal weapon bad boys
right that's where that's where we
pulled from that's what i'm saying like
when you talked about the buddy the old
school buddy cop thing i'm like that
you nailed it oh my god all right
i'm gonna say that i'm psychic at least
in the comments
[Laughter]
um the uh the anthony and sebastian
pairing
it really felt like peanut butter and
chocolate like two things you didn't
know went together so well but then once
you did you don't want to ever take them
apart
can you think of any other pairings just
in the mcu or period maybe you'd like to
see
um sort of maybe the next chapter maybe
some folks teaming up i thought i would
like to see a tony stark
and nebula story that's just me but is
there anybody you want to see team up
there there are characters in our series
uh who i would love
to see partnered with like that's
it's a very very grounded character
partnered with one of the big
uh what are they calling the world
shakers you know i'm saying like thor or
someone like that
you know i'm saying who hasn't moved on
because the personality is so strong
it's the episode 5 character
i'd love to see that character with thor
all right folks listen ahead pay
attention to episode 5.
also i'm going to steal world shakers to
reference the sort of big
uh heroes and the avengers that's a
great way to put that
um lastly you talked about kevin feige
and obviously
you know there were marvel television
shows prior to this but i think he was
very particular about what he wanted in
general for telling
these characters episodically can you
maybe talk about how
he wanted it to change or did he even
make any changes no it was a mandate and
that was one of the things i am most
proud to have been if we are most i
should say we it's not even
high kevin said i want each episode to
feel like a movie
this should not feel like tv not just as
far as the spectacle which you see
is off the charts right but movie
storytelling has a
it has an intensity and a compressed
time to it right
and event quality so he said each
episode has to
feel like a movie yet when you accordion
across six episodes it has to play as
one continuum that serialized
storytelling that you find in the wire
breaking bad or any of that stuff and we
worked
very hard to find and hybrid so that it
did not feel
anything like tv um and really honored
the fact that we were working with
marvel the people who make marvel movies
so we're partners co-workers not
necessarily a team
we look damn good though